[Music]
in the previous video we glanced at the
simple permanent tissues and now before
moving ahead with the complex type we
need to stop by the concept of epidermis
the single layer of cells covering
almost the entire plant body we humans
need a layer of skin to protect our
internal visceral organs and systems
right plants are not an exception to
this they also require and possess a
protective covering throughout their
body which we refer to as the epidermis
so do you think all plants will have the
same structure and same type of
epidermis layer well actually not
epidermis gets modified depending upon
the habitat and does the plants need let
me ask you a question what would plants
growing in the dry habitat need the most
yes water in case of such plants the
epidermis forms a thicker layer in order
to prevent excessive water loss in fact
plants growing in desert have a thick
waxy chemical called q10 in their
epidermal cells which prevents water
loss to the maximum extent on the other
hand in terrestrial plants usually the
aerial parts have epidermal cells
specialized in vacci secretions and it
has in numerous ways like preventing
parasitic infection protection against
mechanical injuries and even loss of
excessive water during high temperatures
in addition to this when we observe the
roots of plants we find tiny numerous
hair like structures these are also the
modifications of the epidermal cells
which help in increasing the surface
area of absorption talking about the
structures now since they are forming a
protective layer it is obvious that they
do not possess intercellular spaces also
the cells are very flat in appearance
and possess a comparatively thicker
outer cell wall wait a second are you
saying that the complete plant body has
a layer of epidermis
then how does the gaseous exchange along
with the water vapor release occur
well the epidermis is clever enough to
leave some spaces or precisely pores in
its structures yes the structures of
pores which we commonly refer to as
stomata are the spots where the
epidermal cells form pits or openings
and are guarded by the kidney-shaped
guard cells the guard cells guide and
regulate the exchange of gases and also
the water vapor from the stomata well
till now we have been talking about the
leaves and roots now let's talk about
the stem do you think the staff will
also possess the same type of epidermal
layer as that in the leaves and roots
actually not in fact stems of huge trees
do not even possess a proper epidermal
layer yes you heard me right in plants
which are much older the epidermis is
replaced by secondary meristem which we
usually refer to as the thick cork or
simply the bark cells of these layers
are dead and compactly arranged without
intercellular spaces also we find
deposits of suberin which regulates
gaseous exchange and water loss well
this video gave you a brief idea about
epidermis now let's move ahead and
describe complex permanent tissues in
the next lesson
[Music]